comme des millions de français les
habitants de l'agglomération rouennaise
sont confinés chez eux depuis le 17 mars
dernier l'entreprise lubrizol a déjà
commencé le nettoyage du site
mais voilà depuis qu'ils sont confinés
chez eux les riverains se plaignent
d'être incommodé tard de fortes odeurs
lorsque les odeurs sont vraiment très
omniprésente cela crée des maux de tête
cela crée des picotements au niveau de
la bouche vraiment des soucis de santé
donc l'urgence allait là c'est à dire
que pour ces personnes qui sont faibles
malade il faut absolument un plan
d'urgence faut absolument qu'elle puisse
sortir de ce périmètre d'odeurs on n'a
droit qu'à un kilomètre aux alentours de
sortie sont toujours confrontés à ces
odeurs toxiques dans une lettre adressée
à la préfecture de seine-maritime
l'association des sinistrés de lubrizol
demande des réponses et une action des
pouvoirs publics
certains voudraient suspendre les
travaux de nettoyage suspecté d'être la
source des dernières nuisances
olfactives
un timing qui ne serait pas le bon selon
pierre andré durand préfet de seine
maritime
l'association dit des sinistrés lubrizol
effectivement m'a écrit il il ya peu
pour faire état d'odeurs qui était tout
à fait incommodante pour le pour le
voisinage
donc j'ai demandé à l'exploitant d'être
très attentif à ses procès cela ses
modes opératoires de nettoyage pour
faire en sorte que ces odeurs digne pour
être une idée de dire reporter ses
travaux à la sortie du confinement
je crains qu'elle ne soit
contre-productive voit qu'elle soit
peut-être même plus gênante parce que
nous allons aller vers de très fortes
chaleurs et plus il restera de matériaux
sur le site plus l'inconfort sera sera
réelle du côté de la justice
l'instruction suit actuellement son
cours
l'odeur nauséabonde pourrait être une
nouvelle pièce ajoutée au dossier mettra
massardi qui défend l'association des
sinistrés de lubrizol insiste sur le
préjudice psychologique infligé aux
riverains avec le confinement s'est
beaucoup de personnes qui subissent les
odeurs et qui ont donc l'impression que
ils ne seront jamais reconnus dans leur
statut de victimes donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut continuer à se mobiliser je
le redis encore une fois
ce qu' il ne faut pas baisser les bras
il faut faire reconnaître ce statut
alors qu'on a des conséquences qui
existe encore aujourd'hui et qui sont
majeurs quand on peut pas aller dans son
jardin parce que il ya des odeurs qui
sont trop présentes qu'on est obligé de
calfeutrer ses portes pour être dans son
domicile
c'est intolérable au sein de lubrizol le
nettoyage se poursuit les salariés de
l'entreprise en temps de retrouver le
cours d'une vie normale rapidement le
gros travail de fut donc été fait déjà
ternie depuis quelques semaines et là
maintenant on passe à partie nettoyage
du terrain donc voila tout se passe bien
d' équipe très compétente un très bon
suivi tout se passe vraiment très bien a
rarement nous rien a déploré les travaux
de nettoyage sont donc maintenus sur le
site de lubrizol
plusieurs semaines seront encore
nécessaires avant un possible retour à
la normale d'ici là riverains et
salariés devront prendre leur mal en
patience